all right so you're ready to get a go
pie go I'm going to be putting links in
the description for basically all of the
parts that you're going to need as well
as run through the initial setup process
and stuff for you guys so uh you there's
basically two major options here you can
either get like the base kit and then
piece together the rest of the stuff
that you need for your go pie go or you
can buy everything all together now
you'll save yourself about $50 if you
piece it together and then basically
anything if you already have say
Raspberry Pi or some of the other parts
you'll save yourself even more money so
to me it's better to get the base kit
and then piece it together but you can
do what you want the simplest option is
of course to just buy the whole kit but
$50 is a little bit extra if you ask me
that's a missile launcher right there so
anyway I'll put links in the description
for all the parts that we're going to be
talking about here they are Amazon
affiliate links so if you use them
you're supporting me in the channel so
thanks a lot for anybody who does
actually use them so first of all it the
go p-- aegyo is made by Dexter
industries and we can come to their
website click on robots here and then
click the go p-- I go so scrolling down
you'll see they offer a base kit and a
starter kit and also a classroom kit but
we're not worried about the classroom
kit so the starter kit is $200 versus
the base kit is $90 so you can get this
and it comes with basically it comes
with a Raspberry Pi model b+ the base
kit the servo package and a distance
sensor so there's that and whoops I hit
my back button um so you can get that or
you can get the base kit pieces together
and save yourself a little bit more
money so anyways continuing along here
step one would be the go p-- aegyo base
kit so you can get this here or through
Dexter industries comm again if you want
to support me in the channel you can get
it here it's the same price won't really
change anything it's actually even sold
by Dexter industries so anyways there's
that so you'll need the base kit after
that you're going to need a Raspberry Pi
now you can either get model B or the
model B+ I believe you could get away
with the Raspberry Pi too but you might
have to add some code in so I'm not
positive how easy that would be for some
of you so if you want to stay safe I
would either get the B or the B plus
next up you need a microSD card now
their image is a 4 gigabyte ish image
but as you may or may not know 4
gigabytes does not mean 4 gigabytes it
means about 3.6 or so so if you want to
be safe I would get at least 8 gigabytes
8 gigabyte SD card is $4 so might as
well go with the 8 you can find SD card
I formatted one of my 4 gigabytes and I
did not have enough space for their
little custom image so just keep that in
mind so I would get at least an 8 I
usually get 16 though and 16 is $2.00
more
so there's that as you need SD card and
then finally the other must have is the
edimax Wi-Fi adapter so these are the
main things that you'll need the base
kit raspberry pi SD card for the
Raspberry Pi and an edimax Wi-Fi adapter
one thing to note if you get the B+ or a
later Raspberry Pi you'll need to have
an SD card that's actually like it's a
SD adapter for a micro SD card ok so
keep that in mind because the B+ and
later only take micro SD cards it saves
a lot of space and also on the older
models the SD card really stuck out and
it was just really easy to break it so
it's a good idea to just go ahead and
get the micro SD so you can be
compatible with all the PI's moving
right along
that was the edimax Wi-Fi adapter you'll
need that then you have a distance
sensor now you can you this distance
sensor from two places this is the basic
distance sensor and as you'll see
there's no uh nope cords here so if you
don't have any jumper cables or jumper
wires what you're going to want to do
probably is splurge for the distance
sensor that Dexter industry sells it's
$19.99 so it's considerably more than
the basic distance sensor does the exact
same thing but it's a little it has like
a little plug here and it comes with the
cord that you need that has you know the
the ground the trigger the sensor and
the power and so it's just really easy
but if you have some jumper cables
around
I would just go with this one it's way
cheaper but choose whichever one you
want they don't sell this one on Amazon
so you'll have to get it through Dexter
industries
next up Raspberry Pi camera module this
is so your robot can see so for example
here we have uh me doing my lovely
tutorial right now with my coffee that's
on on e at the moment so I might pass
out at any moment
uh anyway so you got this this is so you
can stream and see what your pi is doing
and all that so that's really useful to
have also in the later tutorials we're
going to be working with open CV so this
is just so you can see what your robot
sees but with open CV that'll all be
kind of behind the scenes you won't
really have to worry about that but the
camera module is really cool to have it
is a mere like 25 now $23 free shipping
so cheap and it's really cool to have so
I highly recommend the camera module if
you don't already have one anyways
moving right along the servo package
this is so basically you have it here
you can also see it on my go p-- i go
here on the screen this is so you can
connect your distant sensor and your
camera to the servo and then you can
kind of you can swivel swivel
you can swivel the camera around and
kind of look around with your camera on
your distance sensor this is probably
the least mess the second to least
necessary addition to your go p-- i go
but i think it's really cool and for $13
I mean might as well so next we have the
missile launcher this is the least
necessary but it's also the coolest
thing that you can add to it if you ask
me so do what you want we're going to be
covering using we will cover using the
servo package here and we will also
cover using the missile launcher you can
actually have your robot automatically
fire missiles at things so that's really
cool so I highly recommend it but it is
$45 which is kind of high but it does
shoot these things for like 20 feet so
that's pretty cool actually I think it
says 25 feet that's the promise so
anyway I think it's cool but probably
the least necessary thing if you're
needing to save some money next up we
have the tutorial
basically so that's all the stuff that
you need we will have tutorials covering
how to use all of this stuff calculating
distances using the camera especially
OpenCV we'll be doing some more advanced
tutorials with this camera module the
servo like I said it's not super
necessary you can always just turn your
robot you can make the robot itself
rotate if you need to look around so
just you can keep that in mind if you
want this thing is pretty cool we're
gonna actually we're going to try to
have it automatically shoot targets so
so it'll be kind of cool to have it but
again you won't necessarily need it to
follow along once you have your go PI go
and all your parts the next step is to
put it together so Dexter industries if
you go here to robot scope I go looking
for go by go instructions yep we are
getting started you'll click on that and
these are all you need to assemble the
go PI go you can click on that and
there's an instructions you can either
get step-by-step instructions and kind
of like written form for the go Pago
servo package in the camera but they
also have video instructions for all of
this stuff so it's extremely simple I
really applaud Dexter industries for how
simple they made this go pi go I realize
it's a lot of little parts that we're
kind of throwing at you but as far as
robotics go this is really simple to put
all this stuff together so that's really
cool now after that once you have it
together you want to connect to the go
PI go there's a lot of options and
there's you know depending on your
operating system how you're going to do
this my personal preference is to
connect via SSH now that's going to
entail usually plugging in an Ethernet
cable like a cat 5 to your goat or your
Raspberry Pi
scanning for IP addresses connecting
that way and so you can either do that
to first figure out what your IP address
is because you connect you can have your
Wi-Fi adapter but until you know what
the IP address is and then also until
you actually connect to your Wi-Fi
network on your Raspberry Pi you're not
gonna be able to connect remotely but
anyway section 4 here connect to the go
PI go really simple I recommend use
option number 3 or option number 2 but 3
is where you're eventually going to have
to get like there's no point of having a
robot if you always have to have an
your net cord attached to it so um so
definitely I would go three
I also learned something new on Windows
you can get Bonjour which is like a
printer application and you can
automatically scan and find your PI and
connect to it via Bonjour which I
thought like that's really cool I've
never heard of anybody doing that so um
you know for the first time that you
connect to it that makes a lot of sense
if you've never had to go through the
process maybe you won't respect that as
much but that's pretty cool
so anyways you'll connect it you got to
get the IP it at least initially somehow
another easy ways is to connect a
monitor to it connect your Ethernet or
your cat5 cable boot up your Raspberry
Pi and usually when you finally get to
the login screen just a bit above where
you're going to log in it'll literally
say where your IP addresses so then you
can connect via SSH which is here so
like my PI's IP address local is 192 168
0 109 so then from putty we log in that
way so then uh there's that also if you
haven't got to that point to you're
going to need to also install like your
operating system to your Raspberry Pi if
you get the kit it'll come with a four
gigabyte SD card with it already on
there if you buy your own SD card you're
gonna have to format it and install and
mount the image now that sounds really
complex but it's not and actually you
can they have tutorials on Dexter
industries again you can also find a
really easy tutorial on raspberry PI's
website but this one's good enough to
you've got modify your own image and
let's see I'm looking for ya right here
option if you come to option number two
here download and use ours if you want
to download modifiable whoa we have
step-by-step instructions here for
mounting the image so you come here and
again we've got it by a SD or abaya
operating system say if you're on PC you
download their image cool you extract it
cool then use win32diskimager yup and
you mount the image really easy
tutorials just follow it it's step by
step and that's exactly how you're
supposed to do it so easy enough now
that you've got your operating system at
that point you're ready to rumble
actually start programming so again I
realize that's kind of a lot of stuff to
throw at you in one video but once you
get it all together you'll find that
from here it's just smooth sailing
you just have to program the go p-- I go
now but luckily for you there's like a
base kind of framework or API whatever
you want to call it built alongside the
go p-- i go board so like getting your
let's say you want to make your go pay
go go forward that is as simple as FWD
open close parenthesis enter boom your
go pie goes going forward right and so
getting it to move is extremely simple
if you followed along our more advanced
a robotic series here then you probably
remember wiring it up was kind of a pain
and then actually controlling the
h-bridge to get your motors because your
motors go both forward and backwards
right so getting the h-bridge is
configured and setup and then you know
which which io pins do you need to
trigger and send signals to i mean it
was it was kind of confusing so this
would be like a little bit more of an
advanced kind of robotic series but as
far as robotics logic is concerned using
the go p-- aegyo is incredibly simple
and definitely worth worth your while
it's really nice and it's great for
especially beginners and stuff like that
but then you can actually start getting
advanced with it pretty quick so I
really like it so far I'm a big fan of
the go p-- I go at this point so anyway
that's what you guys have to look
forward to what we're going to do in the
next tutorial is get our go p-- i go to
be controlled remotely by us using our
keyboard so we'll start off with that
we'll talk about autonomy in the
subsequent video using the distance
sensor and all that and then after that
we'll be diving into the enamel also
actually we'll cover how to use the
missile launch or to buy your keyboard
which is pretty cool and then after that
we'll talk about using the camera module
OpenCV and all that to automatically
detect stuff and all that so OpenCV is
really cool because you start getting
into like image recognition and stuff
and so that's a really exciting thing
and then getting your go PI go or
whatever robot you're working with
automatically detect things and do
things that's really really cool so
anyways
that's what you guys have to look
forward to if you have any questions
comments concerns whatever getting your
go PI goes set up to the point where at
least you can log into your go PI go
like this please feel free to leave them
below I'm using putty on Windows and
then also for the GUI file system I use
Wynn SCP I highly recommend winscp
otherwise if you can get to this point
then you're ready to continue on to the
next tutorial so stay tuned flat